[Music]
our sun looks nothing like this
it looks more like this
if you've always thought our son was a
bright yellow ball of fire you were
wrong for starters it's not yellow it's
green
sort of
scientists determine the temperature of
a star by the color spectrum it emits
each color has its own wavelength and
astronomers measure those wavelengths to
tell how hot a star is
cooler stars appear red the hottest of
the stars look blue
our sun emits most of its energy at a
wavelength that's close to Green
but because it also emits other
wavelengths all these colors mixed
together and your eyes see this vibrant
mixture as white
that is if you look at the Sun from the
International Space Station from here on
Earth the Sun looks yellow because our
atmosphere is really good at scattering
blue light
and with all that blue wavelength gone
all the other colors combine into yellow
if our star was actually yellow it would
be about 800 degrees Celsius cooler our
Solar System's habitable zone would
shrink and Earth would become a frozen
lifeless Rock
but that's not the only thing you were
wrong about
the Sun is hot but it's not on fire
burning is a chemical reaction of oxygen
fuel
like most stars out there our sun is a
ball of gas mostly made up of hydrogen
and helium it doesn't have much oxygen
in it
instead it works more like a gigantic
nuclear reactor constantly fusing
hydrogen atoms to create helium inside
its core
this process releases enormous amounts
of energy and that's why the sun is so
scorching hot
speaking of setting things on fire let
me tell you about explosions in space
yeah these aren't real
a spaceship can't go down in a violent
blast because there's no air out there
in space
no air means no oxygen and no oxygen
well as you already know means no fire
sorry Star Wars fans
it may seem that there are too many
stars in the night sky for you to count
but actually you can
although scientists at Harvard have
already done it for you
according to the Yale bright star
catalog there are 9110 stars that you
can see from Earth with the naked eye
try to count them all for yourself
movies make it look like you need to be
an extremely skilled pilot to navigate
the asteroid belt but that's not true
the asteroid belt isn't some thick
obstacle course of death
it does have trillions of space rocks
that range in size from space dust to a
quarter the size of the Moon about 100
000 of these asteroids are over one
kilometer wide but they're very spread
out
the asteroid belt between Mars and
Jupiter is
225 million kilometers across
that's one and a half times the distance
between Earth and the Sun
and this spreads the space rocks
millions of kilometers apart it's almost
impossible for a spacecraft to collide
with one if you were thrown out of the
airlock into the vastness of space you
wouldn't turn into a popsicle right away
that's because to freeze there has to be
a heat transfer from space to your body
but heat or cold doesn't travel very
fast in the vacuum of space
your body would freeze but it would take
hours to happen
and by then you'd be long dead from
something else and no you wouldn't
explode in space either
you would inflate though that's because
nitrogen in your bloodstream would
gather into bubbles and puff you up to
double your size
but that's not what's going to kill you
it's the lack of oxygen after 15 seconds
in space your brain wouldn't get enough
oxygen through your blood
and you'd lose consciousness
after two minutes in space your other
organs would start to shut down one by
one
game over
[Music]
space seems incredibly cold but it's not
in reality space doesn't have a
temperature at all
temperature is defined by the speed at
which particles move and the amount of
energy they have
in the true vacuum of space there are no
particles to move around
that's why the vacuum is temperatureless
of course outer space isn't a perfect
vacuum it still has particles and
radiation to produce heat
some areas of space are actually really
hot like the space around Stars
but the further away you get from Stars
the more spread out the particles are
making those areas of space pretty
chilly
some dense gas clouds can get as cold as
minus 263 degrees Celsius
Mercury is the closest planet to the Sun
but surprisingly it's not the hottest
it is Extreme though during the day the
surface temperature reaches 430 degrees
and at night it drops to minus 180.
but the most hellish planet in the solar
system is Venus
Mercury doesn't have an atmosphere to
retain all that heat from the Sun
the venusian atmosphere on the other
hand is very thick and it creates a
greenhouse effect
it's like global warming on steroids and
it makes Venus a hot hell with a surface
temperature of about
475 degrees
our entire solar system isn't just
sitting in one spot in our galaxy
it's hurtling through space at 220
kilometers per second
that's seven times faster than the speed
that Earth revolves around the Sun
our solar system takes 230 million years
to make one orbit around the Milky Way
yeah the last time we were in the same
location we are now Earth had one
supercontinent and the dinosaurs were
just starting to roam around
planets do not orbit around the sun
all the things in our solar system are
in balance and even though the sun is
the most massive object in our planetary
neighborhood other planets are
participating in this gravitational tug
of war
instead of orbiting the Sun planets and
moons orbit around a central point
between them and our star
this point is called the Berry Center
for Earth this Berry Center is so close
to the sun's core that there's not much
of a difference but for Jupiter this
point is about 55 000 kilometers away
from the center of the Sun
so the gas giant and the sun are
orbiting each other
Earth appears round from space but it's
actually an irregularly shaped ellipsoid
it bulges at the equator thanks to the
centrifugal force caused by our planet's
spin
as a result Earth is about 43 kilometers
wider at the equator than it is at the
poles
this makes gravity at the Bulge slightly
weaker making it easier to launch
spaceships from the equatorial regions
than from the poles
in space no one can hear you scream
and that's only true to a point
sound needs a medium to travel through
and in space molecules are very far
apart so the sound Fades away before it
can get very far
all the cosmic catastrophes supernovas
and colliding black holes go quiet
before you can hear them but some places
in space have a lot of particles for
sound to travel through
like the hot gas cloud around the black
hole at the center of the Perseus Galaxy
cluster
it has so much gas that you can actually
hear the black hole this is what it
sounds like
thank you you know other planets make
noise too
if you could hear them do you know what
they would sound like
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]